Millions of Pokemon Go trainers around the
world are exploring their communities in a
quest to catch 'em all.
The app doesn't have very much of an in-game
tutorial system, so we've compiled a list
of the most essential things you should know
before setting forth in search of a Dragonair
or Mewtwo.
I choose you, Pikachu!
Want to be just like Ash and get Pikachu as
your starter Pokemon?
It takes a little bit of work.
When Professor Willow presents you with a
Bulbasaur, Squirtle, and Charmander on your
map, simply walk away from them.
Once you get out of range, the three critters
will appear again next to you.
Repeat the process, walking away from them
four times.
The next time they reappear, a Pikachu will
also be there waiting for you.
And the circle is complete.
Sort your Pokemon
Tired of scrolling through your bag in search
of that Clefairy you know you caught yesterday?
Take advantage of the in-game sorting options.
On the Pokemon view interface, tap the icon
at the bottom right of the screen.
You'll be given numerous sorting options to
choose from, including name, time caught,
combat power, hit points, Pokedex number,
and other information.
Pokemon tracking
Pokemon that show up in the "nearby" list
won't come closer to you if you use an Incense
or Lure Module, since those are determined
randomly and don't require movement for them
to spawn.
The number of footprints below a Pokemon in
the list indicates their distance, and each
footprint represents approximately 30 to 50
meters.
You can tap on the list to open a grid and
use it to navigate.
Tap on your target in the list, then start
walking.
As you get closer, the targeted critter will
move up and to the left on the list.
If you're walking in the wrong direction,
the Pokemon will move down and to the right
on the grid.
When it reaches the top-left position on the
grid, it will be the closest Pokemon to you.
Keep homing in and the footprints will drop
to two, then one, then none when you're right
next to it.
Great throws
Catching Pokemon isn't as simple as just chucking
a Pokeball at an animal’s head.
When you target a creature, holding your finger
down on the Pokeball will generate a shrinking
target ring.
The ring colors indicate how difficult each
creature is to catch.
Green is easy, yellow is average, orange is
difficult, and red is very hard.
Toss your Pokeball through the colored circle
as it shrinks.
Accuracy nets additional XP and a higher catch
chance.
You can spin your Pokeball until it sparkles
right before you toss it and get a "Curveball"
XP bonus.
Super Balls and Ultra Balls can make catching
Pokemon with orange and red targeting circles
easier.
Pokemon can be bribed with "razz berries"
which also increase your chances… but only
for one throw.
Fighting gym battles
Just like catching Pokemon, battling with
them is more complicated than it seems.
Your creatures all have two attack moves:
a primary move and a "special" one that must
charge up.
When fighting at a gym, tap your Pokemon to
use the primary move, and keep an eye on the
special move bar located below your Pokemon's
name.
When the special meter is full, hold down
your finger on your Pokemon to unleash their
special move.
Don't forget you can also swipe left or right
to dodge incoming attacks.
Keep these tips in mind and your next fight
should be super-effective.
Diversity is key
Before you go charging into an enemy Gym with
six wimpy Pidgeys, remember that Pokemon types
are essentially a more complex version of
Rock, Paper, Scissors.
Grass beats water, water beats fire, fire
beats grass, and so on, so you should build
a diverse team that's best suited to fight
the Pokemon defending the gym.
When you initiate a gym battle, you'll be
shown your team of six at the bottom of your
screen.
Tap any Pokemon to switch them out with another
from your collection, then start the battle
when you're ready.
Gym takeovers
If you win a battle at an enemy gym, you may
be surprised when the enemy team retains possession
of it.
That's because gym ownership is based on overall
team prestige.
You may have to battle a gym successfully
multiple times in a row to lower the gym's
prestige to zero.
Bring friends along to make the takeover process
faster.
Once it hits zero, the gym will become neutral
and you can install one of your own Pokemon
to defend it.
Gym leaders are determined by which Pokemon
at that gym leads in Combat Points, or CP.
For every gym you lead or support, you'll
get a daily package filled with Pokecoins
for use in the online shop.
Train your Pokemon
Gyms also have levels of their own, based
on their battle prestige.
The higher level the gym is, the more people
on your team can put Pokemon in the gym.
The more Pokemon there are in a gym, the harder
it is for challengers to initiate a takeover.
Training your Pokemon is simple—just visit
a Gym that's already controlled by your team.
Once there, you can train by battling against
your own team's Pokemon.
Defeat all of them and your Gym's Prestige
will go up, making it more difficult to be
defeated by another team, and also opening
new slots for more defenders to be added.
Smart evolutions
Hold on to your highest CP Pokemon, and transfer
lower-level duplicates to Professor Willow
in exchange for candy.
Don't waste your candy evolving a Pokemon
if it has a low CP bar.
While it'll still get a relative boost in
power, it will be in the exact same position
on the CP arc in its evolved form, and cost
you more candy and Stardust to power up.
Aim to evolve Pokemon that are already strong
in CP, or power them up first before evolving.
If a Pokemon's CP arc is completely full,
that means you cannot power them up any further
due to your trainer's level.
Level up your trainer first, and then that
Pokemon will have space to be powered up again.
Battery saver mode and battery packs
Here's a tip for trainers in the real world,
not the digital one.
The game and the GPS tracking it can drain
your phone's battery life quickly.
Additionally, you can leave the app open to
get notifications of nearby Pokemon.
To get the most game time out of your device,
close your other apps and turn on your phone's
"Battery Saver" option.
You should also invest in a couple of portable
power banks to charge your phone.
Only buy ones that pack at least 10,000 milliamp
hours of charge, and you should be able to
stay in business catching Pokemon for several
hours straight.
Just don't blame us if you use up all your
data playing Pokemon Go.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
Pokemon Go tips you think are super effective...